vu de france bonjour régis chamagne vu
de france
à quoi servent ce type de conférence je
pense que ça peut servir à remettre les
choses à plat
parler du droit international à faire un
peu de vélo de tout ce qui se passe dans
le monde et de toutes les agressions qui
sont commises parfois au nom des droits
de l'homme mais surtout sur des des
raisons de prédation parce qu'il n'ya
pas de guerre juste que les guerres de
prédation des guerres pour carte est ce
que l'autre a est ce que l'on n'a pas
donc c'est pas mal de temps en temps de
remettre un peu tout ça je vais te dire
comment là où à l'humanité voit et ce
qu'on veut vivre en paix ou via ce qu'on
veut continuer à faire des guerres comme
ça en ce qui est intéressant c'est que
il y a eu récemment on l'a vu là qu'on
fait la conférence de l'otan avons là la
rencontre entre joe biden et vladimir
poutine
c'est une semaine finalement assez
chargé en ce qui concerne la stratégie
ou de la stabilité
de la paix dans le monde oui c'est
normal nous vivons une période assez
unique dans l'humanité un changement de
paradigme au jury qui complet nous avons
vécu sur dans un monde à peu près stable
après la seconde guerre mondiale jusqu'à
il ya environ une vingtaine d'années
brun 15 ans est là depuis une quinzaine
d'années je veux dire allez depuis 2005
le monde a opéré une passe incomplète
nous allons vivre un autre paradigme qui
n'est pas encore là qui est en train de
se faire bien pour tous en train de se
mettre en place et je pense que dans le
cadre de ce changement de cette mutation
que d'aucuns perçu et que d'autres
refusent de voir il est pas mal de se
réunir et de parler un peu de sécurité
vous avez entendu le le chef du kremlin
s'exprimer il a exposé en quelques
lignes la position de la russie pour la
contribution à cette stabilité dans le
monde il a évoqué la contribution de son
pays à la résolution notamment des
conflits régionaux
la russie joue un rôle prépondérant dans
cette stabilité mondiale selon vous oui
il ya sur ce que j'ai retenu de du
discours de la lumière footing ces cas
et elle s'appuie sur le droit
international
à plusieurs reprises il a prononcé le
mot droit international c'est normal
poutine a une formation de juriste
donc il veut et quand il revient
toujours à cela la deuxième chose c'est
qu'il affirme la posture stratégique de
la russie qui est une posture défensive
qui se dote d'une arme est calculée au
juste niveau pour assurer sa protection
la protection de la russie et du peuple
russe donc posture défensive et en entre
les lignes
on comprend bien qu'il qu'il désigne
l'otan comme fauteurs de troubles
aujourd'hui dans le monde à travers les
révolutions de couleur il l'a dit et les
les
les guerres ou les agressions qui se
déroulent un peu partout dans le monde
donc il ne le dit pas clairement mais
tout le monde a bien compris son message
la russie est dans une posture
stratégique défensive elle participe à
la stabilité dans le monde contre le
temps qui lui est accrue si l on
continue de décrypter cette conférence
avec régis chamagne qui étaient avec
nous régissent chamaillent merci
beaucoup d'être resté vous parlez d'un
autre paradigme qui n'avait pas été pris
en compte dans la stabilité mondiale
j'aimerais savoir quel est cet autre
paradigme sergueï choïgou qui a énoncé
toutes les tous les foyers d'instabilité
dans le monde et ils sont nombreux
il a insisté sur le rôle de l'onu le
président vladimir poutine l'a dit dans
son discours inaugural
kelly c est pareil cette autre paradigme
finalement que les occidentaux ceux qui
ne sont pas justement aujourd'hui à
moscou ne comprennent pas je pense que
le nouveau par lille qui se dessine le
sait la fin de l'hégémonie américaine
sur le monde l'avait gémonies militaires
et économiques et la fin de la
globalisation la tentative de
globalisation qui allait avec et c'est
le retour aux états nations et aux
puissances régionales on l'appelle
voilà c'est c'est ça le nouveau
paradigme où là après la chute de
l'union soviétique il ya eu la guerre
froide après la chute de l'union
soviétique les les occidentaux ont
dépensé qu'ils avaient gagné et que les
américains en particulier accélérer leur
mise et l'analyse sur le sur l'occident
d'abord sur leurs partenaires
entre rumeurs prêtent leurs vassaux
occidentaux et ils ont pensé qu'ils
allaient pouvoir dominer le monde avec
une armée surpuissante à côté et une
économie conquérante de l'autre et bien
cette idée là ce projet là et est
terminée et aujourd'hui on revient aux
états nations
on va probablement au pouvoir l'union
européenne se dissoudre dans quelques
années et on va revenir aux états
nations et à la fin à la fin de tout ce
processus
c'est ça le vaut parra bible et quand
une bête est blessée elle dangereuse et
c'est pour ça que une remise à plat des
cartes et et laisser serre dans le
respect du droit que rachida merci
beaucoup régis chamagne pour votre
intervention
ce matin en direct